[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we will spot out the differences between
the two races of Navi seen in Avatar 2
the way of water the metakaina and the
umatagaya or the oceanic Clans and the
forest Clans the same species but with a
few traits that they have evolved to
better suit their own environments so
let's look at their differences
firstly let's start with the origins
they are a race of aliens who inhabit
the jungle Moon called Pandora an
Earth-like Moon of the planet
polyphemers which orbits Alpha Centauri
the closest star system to ours although
scientists believe that the navi are a
single species there is a great deal of
diversity and variety among them equal
to dog breeds and they exhibit
indications of Rapid Evolution to
environments we speculate that the navi
is separated from the main pandoran
evolutionary tree quite a long time ago
this is seen by the existence of the pro
limerus which is kind of like brunt of
primates of Pandora and its resemblance
to the navi but it is hexapedal while
the navi are bipedal bipedal tetrapods
so any link between the navi and the
animal species is still theories and up
to research
now there are quite a few Clans and
races of the Navi on Pandora excluding
the avatars made by humans the navi
lives in territorial Clan societies
across Pandora's biomes similar to
Villages and tribes these exist in every
biome on Pandora each with its own
distinct culture and in some cases even
a different physiology as we will
showcase here the different Clans are
connected via Commerce and Customs
despite their diversity and distance
from one another aside from the forests
and ocean Clans there are 14 moles such
as the anurai the olangi the tipani and
the tunkanui so as of now we will look
specifically at the forest clan of
matigaya and the ocean Clans the
metraina as for the limbic systems the
arms the legs the differences are more
pronounced here the arms of the forest
Clans are slim and long but also highly
developed muscle fibers are present
there while the oceanic Clans have a
bigger set of arms which are widened in
the lower part via extended cartilage
and webbing-like connections between
fingers the same could be said about the
legs and the lower leg part being wider
and having a similar webbing and the
extension of the cartilage which makes
them look like flippers
in which both adaptations help the navi
swim faster and become more hydronomic
the biggest difference here is seen in
the tail the metcalina's tail is broader
and looks like a paddle at the end and
this allows for steering as well as
propulsion underwater
these navies both of them have humanoid
bodies with feline traits including flat
split noses huge round eyes pointed ears
and a long prehensile tail utilized for
grabbing and balancing while both the
two clans are similar in height which
varies from 2.5 to 3.9 meters or 8.2 to
12.7 feet tall the oceanic Clans have a
bulkier body the metcalina also have a
lighter shade of skin color being more
turquoise rather than the darker blue
shade of the umatikaya the skin of the
ocean Clan Navi also have different wave
like patterns of Stripes which kind of
resembles the wave the breaking waves of
the water as compared to the tiger
stripes of the forest Clans which are
adaptations for camouflage in their
respective environments and also these
wave-like patterns are complemented with
tattoo markings overall the Met kaina
appear to be bigger and bulkier than the
other
there are also quite a few more
physiological differences between the
two the metcaina for instance have
smaller ears than the omatikaya which is
helpful to reduce the chance of water
getting inside them they also have
flattenosis for the same reason
there's still air breathers though so
they've adapted to being able to hold
their breath for long periods of time
and therefore the lung size and capacity
is significantly larger than the
omatikaya they have nictating membranes
kind of like crocodiles and owls to
protect their eyes when they are
underwater they enter the water in high
speed and also their eyes are wider
bigger and more farther apart while the
Forest Clans have sharper eye complex
which is needed in the forest biomes to
focus on prey and the highly dense
serrated jungle environment as they are
also Apex species in their own
respective environments
so those are the anatomical and
physiological differences between the
two clans the metraina and the umatikaya
but then there is another main
difference between these two Clans and
these are the symbiotic species of
animals that they born with
there are three main animals for each
gland geomaticaya's basic state is a
dire horse and can be connected via the
neural pathway with any Navi or even
avatars and this is the same thing with
the ilu the long neck plesiosaur like
marine animal of the metcaina going a
step further is the bond between the
specific Navi individuals and their own
Wall Streets which are the flying
Banshees for the forest Clans while it
is the skim wing for the oceanic Clans
then there is level three the ultimate
symbiosis the bond between the forests
Navi and the turak are the great
leonopteryx becoming torrett makto and
the bond between the metcaina individual
and a tulkin another sentient species of
Pandora and becoming sole companions is
the ultimate level for the metcaina so
those are the differences between the
met kaina and the omatikaya I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam